I'm joined today by George Leakey who
recently retired from Swarthmore College
where he was Eugene and Lange visiting
professor for issues in social change
and manage the global nonviolent action
database research project Viking
economics is his ninth book and it's so
great to talk about it George let's
start sort of generally when we talk
about Viking economics or Nordic
economics Scandinavian economics talked
about it within different terms hugely
stigmatized in the United States by a
certain section of the sort of political
spectrum free stuff that people don't
deserve very high taxes and a bad
business environment right I mean is
there any truth to those stereotypes
not really for example Norway has more
startups per capita than the United
States does it's actually a very
thriving economic environment and they
do support entrepreneurs very strongly
they just don't support them at the
expense of the common good so that the
the genius of the what economists call
the Nordic model is that it keeps
looking out for the well-being of the
whole at the same time as it supports
creativity and innovation and the
economic realm there's this idea that
you know we could have a debate over
what is the sort of right or fair level
of Taxation and that sort of a more uh
abstract question but there's this idea
that objectively taxes are just
outrageously high in many of these
countries but I think what's often not
considered in that is if you are paying
for example health insurance premiums in
the US and you're comparing the tax rate
to a country that has a national health
care system shouldn't you also be
considering your health insurance
premiums into in thinking about sort of
your total tax rate if comparing to a
country that has a national health care
system I mean I am I wrong about that or
would that be how no they didn't a price
to apples comparison that's right that's
you're completely right in fact when you
ask entrepreneurs who have achieved you
know some
well when you ask them well how do you
feel about these very high taxes that
you pay they said yes but we don't pay
for health insurance we don't need to
send our we don't need to pay for higher
education for our kids we can send our
kids through medical school law school
whatever and we're not actually sending
them through because they're going
through thanks to a an economic system
that makes those in a sense free of
course nothing is really free it's all
paid by taxation on the other hand the
benefits are enormous and many Americans
for example living over there would
actually save money because especially
if they're paying for their own medical
care which can be of course enormous it
can even bankrupt people and also and
nobody's bankrupted by medical care over
there because it's all taken care of
and also map matters like higher
education which again can be something a
lot of young people are now saddled with
enormous debts but that's that's unheard
of in that in that in those countries
let's assume for a second that we could
convince some of these I don't know if
we want to call them supply siders or
call them what you will those who are
very negative about the Nordic economic
system let's assume we could convince
someone that it works well they're right
very often we run up against this
talking point that listen the US can't
do what smaller European countries can
do in terms of health care or social
services etcetera because those
countries are very small and the u.s. is
very big many more people much more
infrastructure and what works there just
could not be applied in the United
States but talk about that a little bit
is there anything to that well the same
thing was said about social security it
would never work for the United States
to have a social security system that's
something Europeans can do but we cannot
and obviously we're well established in
the Social Security system
another example more recent example is
Medicare because again there was a lot
of opposition among supply siders to
having Medicare not only is Medicare
counted on by by tens of millions of
Americans and all over the country but
also
but studies are done about how satisfied
people are with Medicare it turns out
people are much more satisfied with
Medicare than they are with private
individual health insurance and so those
are two systems that are taken for
granted in the Nordic countries they
were imported to the United States and
they get a huge support here in the
United States there's another of sort of
common line from the detractors of many
of the systems that you wrote about in
Viking economics which is what's
different really is not a matter of
scale when you compare the American
economy to Nordic economies but what's
different is that many of those
countries are relatively homogenous and
have less diversity and this is a very
popular talking point for those who are
against uh multiculturalism and
diversity etcetera they say hey the US
could do what they're doing there but we
can't in practice because we just let
anybody into this country and it's too
diverse here and and we have all of the
problems that come with diversity as
they see it talk a little bit about that
with regard to some of these economies
well it was an important research
question for me as well because I didn't
look into those countries not
skeptically you know I was very curious
about how do they handle questions like
diversity and and for that matter
questions of scale and now could that be
applied to our country and on my way
into one of the research outfits that
gave me generously a tremendous lot of
time for interviewing I saw a photograph
on the wall that showed a delegation of
Chinese who had been sent from Beijing
and I said oh why why was this Chinese
delegation here and they said well these
were economists and political scientists
and policymakers who were sent from
Beijing to explore and learn from the
Nohr wage and system and I said how
could that possibly be for exactly the
reasons you just stated and they said
that they asked that same question of
the Chinese they were very surprised the
Chinese were they're tiny you know
Norway is only five million people on
the end and of course China is not only
huge compared with Norway China is huge
compared with the United States and
China is also highly diverse more much
more diverse than the United States is
and so what they the Tiny's delegation
said is our government sent us here to
learn what we can because some
particular policies and structures are
influenced by diversity are influenced
by scale and others are not some things
scale up really well and the Social
Security would be an example of that and
some some things can are very very
doable no matter how much a diversity
there is and again social security would
be an example of that in our own country
because in our own experience Medicare
and Social Security don't aren't
affected by uh you know by the the first
language people happen to speak there
are probably many people who are sort of
generally familiar in my audience with
uh the with Scandinavia and Nordic
economic models but they may sort of see
them as as an amorphous non
distinguished group in your research and
this may be as much of a cultural
question as it is economic what were
some of the most interesting
distinguishing factors between the
countries you studied that might be
interesting to some in our audience one
distinguishing factor is that the
Norwegians are far more distrustful of
corporations of large corporations than
the other countries they're so
distrustful that the Norwegian
government bias controlling interests of
all the large corporations and so when
the Board of Directors meets a certain
number of those seeds you know the
majority actually the controlling
interests are held by the government
itself and that's in order to make sure
that those corporations don't do things
that are against the public interest
that that's a more I would say the know
reasons are more distrustful of
corporate decision making than the other
Nordic countries very very interesting
uh last thing I want to touch on when it
comes to looking at issues like for
example climate change or more uh what
we might consider social issues
you talked a little bit about how the
economic system of the country sort of
influences the views on some of these
other issues that that certainly are
related to economics but maybe less so
in some ways yes well I do have a couple
of chapters in my book Viking economics
on the the things that I say are both
challenges for our country for America
and also challenges for them one
challenge is racism
yes racism does show up in those
countries and as it does so so
prominently in ours and the the what the
reason why they are more optimistic
actually than we are about handling
racism is because they have the Nordic
economic model on their side so for
example people with talent to go to
university are not handicapped by their
financial situation they may be very
recent immigrants they may come from you
know a very impoverished countries that
have their previous life and then
suddenly there they are in Norway or
Sweden or Denmark and they're able to go
all you know all the way as far as their
talent will take them and so that means
that the even though the family they
came with maybe it could remain
desperate poor for a while until they
get their feet under under them the
members of their family that are able to
take advantage of the tremendous
training and educational opportunities
there can just go right for it they're
not frozen out for a few generations
while people slowly try to get as often
is the case here try to get into the
system for upward mobility so those
countries have what much more upward
mobility than the United States does it
used to be the reverse it used to be
they had person you know if you were
born into working class that's where you
stayed but over there
there's my now in mobility which me
because the economy in turn is benefited
by being rewarded and people being able
to move forward on the things that
really matter to them we have been
speaking about the book Viking economics
which is George Lake he's nine
book thanks so much for talking to us
about this very very interesting you're
welcome very happy to be here